[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Today I'm
having coffee with Adam Dawes
to talk about user identity
on the Google platform
and what's new in our
Sign In with Google APIs.
Tell us what is it that you do
and what are you working with.
ADAM DAWES: I lead Google's
Federated Identity team.
And what I do is I try to build
seamless experiences for users
off of Google.
So going to any
third-party app, users
that have a Google
account, but also
just to really help
developers in the ecosystem
build extremely simple
identity experiences.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now starting
with Google Play Services 8.3,
I can really see how
you've simplified the API.
Can you tell us a
little bit about that?
ADAM DAWES: Google
Sign In, we've
gone through and
kind of basically
redone the whole API, the
whole service from top
to bottom over the last year.
Some of the things that we've
really focused on is trying
to decouple from
the Google+ Sign In,
that launch from
a few years ago,
and to make it radically simpler
for both users and developers
as they build their
sign in experiences.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Users had
a lot of interim screens
that they had to go through
to be able to sign in.
And now that's been
cut drastically.
ADAM DAWES: Yeah, I think
the landscape's changed a lot
over the last couple of years.
And users are a
lot more sensitive
to privacy and the
information that they give.
So we're trying to
lead towards a model
where the user just gives
the bare bones information
to the app and has a super low
friction experience signing
into to the app.
And so we've recentered
Google Sign In around that.
Can I show you what
we're talking about here?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sure.
ADAM DAWES: So let me show
you the Runkeeper app here
that has implemented the
latest Google Sign In API.
So the experience now,
once the user taps that,
they get this new UI,
which includes what
we call account chips here.
Now before, with the Google+
sign in, they got this really
big consent screen with
tons of words on it,
lots of cognitive overload.
It had switches and
controls about which circles
they wanted to share with--
LAURENCE MORONEY: I love the
phrase cognitive overload.
ADAM DAWES: Yes, it was
complicated for the end user.
So what we have here
with the account
chips is what we call a "what
you see is what you give"
consent flow.
So all the user needs to
do is tap on the profile
that they want to log
in as, and they're done.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now
those are the profiles
that are already on the phone?
ADAM DAWES: That's right.
The user signs into the phone
with their Google account.
And then that provides
which accounts
they can log into on the app.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Good thing you've made
it so much easier for users.
How about developers?
I know there's
new APIs out there
and they're supposed to make it
easier and that kind of stuff.
So how does a
developer get started
and how does a developer take
advantage of all of this?
ADAM DAWES: We've totally
transformed the APIs from top
to bottom.
And we've centered them
around OpenID Connect.
So this is the new
authentication standard.
It came out a
couple of years ago.
And it's really
where the industry
is moving to have a very common
language for doing identity
from one IDP to another.
And so every app doesn't
have to reinvent, oh, I
have to talk to this IDP
this way, this IDP that way.
It's all just consistent.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And needing
all that interoperability
can lead to potential
security holes, right?
ADAM DAWES: Exactly-- exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So that consistency
makes you more secure.
ADAM DAWES: Yeah, exactly.
But the real innovation
behind OpenID Connect
is this thing called
the identity token.
It's a blob of JSON
that is signed.
So when you go through
that experience
and you tap on the
account you want
to log in as, that signal
goes back to Google.
And then Google sends out an
identity token back to the app.
And that identity
token, this blob of JSON
basically has the user's
email address, their name,
a couple of other--
their Google ID,
their Google identifier,
not user facing,
but is a unique
identifier for that user.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Because they
can change their email address
but keep the same identities.
ADAM DAWES: Exactly.
So that will tie them together
with that carbon life form
as it goes through those
different manifestations.
And then it's stamped by Google.
It's signed by Google.
And so that's super important
because then the app
knows for sure that that
Google user was really
there on that device.
And the ID tokens
are super portable.
So the app itself can pull out
all the information of the user
and personalize the app
and show the profile photo
and the user's name in the app.
And then it can send that
ID token back to its server.
And it can do that
with its API calls,
which you outlined really
well in your blog post.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thank you.
ADAM DAWES: Then
on the server side,
it can verify that,
again, Google signed this,
and that that Google user was
really there on that device.
And so it makes security a
lot simpler for developers.
And again, they don't have
to reinvent the wheel again.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
it's really important
that it's effectively the
same API infrastructure
on both the mobile
device and on the server,
using the same thing.
Because the more
things that you use,
the greater the potential
attacks are for this, right?
And having this
consistency is really cool.
ADAM DAWES: Exactly.
So we've rebuilt the client
SDKs around OpenID Connect.
And it's super
simple to pull out
that ID to hook in so you
can send it to your server,
or you can just talk to the
SDKs to get out the JSON
so you can personalize
your app right then
and there in context.
And just a much simpler
experience, not, again,
tied in with all of the
social stuff as much.
So if all you want
to do with sign in
is just sign the
user in, then we've
made that path much
more straightforward
for the developer.
LAURENCE MORONEY: One question--
change of course for a second--
but one question
we've heard a lot
and we've seen on Stack Overflow
is with iOS and the problems
with using this technology,
using Google Sign In technology
with iOS.
But that's a thing
of the past now.
ADAM DAWES: Yes, very thankfully
that is a thing of the past.
So some apps had
had some trouble
with Apple, apps that had been
using Google Sign In, Apple
didn't like the fact
that we were popping out
to Safari to do
the sign in event,
which we feel very strongly
about from a security
perspective because that's where
the user actually understands
where they're putting
their credentials,
because they can see in the URL
that they're going to Google.
But it seems like
they agreed that that
was an important thing for
the user to be able to do.
So they invented Safari
View Controller in iOS 9.
And so iOS 9 has much better
navigation characteristics.
It is much more in line
with the application.
It just comes in on the side.
And the user can't get lost.
The user can't go elsewhere.
Once they have a
web browser open,
it's much more tied to the app.
But it has all the
benefits of Safari
where the user sign in
state, if they've already
logged into safari, you
actually get a true single sign
in experience.
If that user's already
logged into Google,
then all it is is a single
tap, just like I showed you,
where the user doesn't
have to sign in to Google
all over again.
LAURENCE MORONEY: A great hidden
benefit to all this of course
is that you don't have to build
all the security infrastructure
yourself and manage and maintain
security infrastructure, given
the environment that
we live in today.
But if I'm a developer and I
want to get started on this,
where should I get started?
What's the best site to go to?
Other than my blogs, of course.
ADAM DAWES: Well, that is
a great place to start.
But you want to go to
developers.google.com/identity.
And that outlines how you
do Google Sign In and Smart
Lock for Passwords, as well as
Google Identity Toolkit, which
all this auth stuff is still
probably more complicated
and requires more time than
many developers want to spend.
And so Google Identity
Toolkit is like your log
in system in a box.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Absolutely.
It's your best friend.
ADAM DAWES: Right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
And any folks
watching this video,
if you have any questions for
me or any questions for you,
leave them in comments below and
we'll be sure to answer them.